I need you to know that this story is
100% real we did not make this up here
it is
rats taught to drive tiny cars to lower
their stress levels that's a true story
so we went online there's even footage
this is real real footage of a rat
driving the car in some kind of
experiment yes this is all part of an
experiment and the researchers they the
researchers say again all true that the
rats relaxed significantly while they
were driving I guess they had sensors
you know and they could tell oh the rats
really relaxed that's all fine but what
I want to know is this
why were these rats so stressed out in
the first place what he's stressing out
all of these rats so I decided to look
into it what what's stressing out the
rats it turns out it's a lot of
different things stress them out take a
look well these two rats just just had a
pregnancy tests come back positive
this rats a day trader who has suffered
some pretty serious losses this rat is
an air traffic controller
yeah true this rat is a general
listening in on Trump's Ukraine phone
call in underbite when I suggesting is a
great broke-broke and finally this rat
is a bomb squad officer defusing a bomb
what is more stressful than that
he when it comes to special effects we
spared no it's best yeah that was made
with a cell phone yeah yeah